yo ya está lleno de simbolismos el papá
llegó a esta función como la explanada
de las iglesias ahí hay 4
iglesia de las diferentes visiones del
cristianismo armenias exiliadas ayc
aldeas y allí en ese lugar no solamente
se refirió y se comunicó con los
cristianos sino también con los
musulmanes y los habitantes de otras
confesiones que viven en 2000 e
históricamente fue conocida como una
ciudad donde vivían comunidades está
turbia kurdos vivian ya bucks de viana y
así vivían cristianos y obviamente eran
mayoría musulmana pues esta fue la
ciudad más afectada durante aquellos
años que el estado islámico se tomó un
tercio del país recordemos a muy pocos
metros de donde estuvo el papá que abu
bakr al al bagdadí declaró el califato y
declaró que mosúl era la capital de ese
califato y ese mismo lugar donde estaba
el pontífice esta mañana era donde
estaba la chiva que era la policía de
elaborarla que haga soldado y la que
hacía la vida imposible a los habitantes
de mosúl esta oración que hizo aquí y
esta plegaria por decir que la paz sigue
triunfando frente a la guerra
en las religiones no pueden ser
utilizadas como un instrumento de
terrorismo es un mensaje muy claro
además hay que entender las condiciones
en que llega el papá aquí llegó si llegó
rodeado de seguridad pero se bajó habló
con la gente le dio la mano no llevaba
chaleco antibalas y en un pequeño
carrito de golf subió hacia la iglesia
principal de esta esperada por ahora la
más destruida a las 3 la iglesia la cnrt
agilidad una iglesia preciosa que ya
tiene una antigua destruida en ese
entonces a principios de 1900 triples y
preciosas y hasta ahí llegó el papá y
también oró en silencio frente a esta
cúpula destruida